Elevator Action, the ups and downs of the Spy Game.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe. No surprises there, guys.
You all said your names correctly.
And it's time to play some...
Let me ask you real fast, Sean.
You a guy who enjoys riding the elevators?
I wear an elevator sometimes.
Okay, I don't know what that means.
I'm kind of concerned. Joe, you like elevators?
I love elevators. I love that elevator action.
Oh, you know the game.
It is elevator action, as we alluded to just moments ago.
This is another Taito game.
No surprises there.
They love to make arcade games that don't translate that well to console experiences.
And it's Micronix again.
Micronix is doing it.
Taito's doing it.
And so the arcade game came out in 1983.
And now it's on the NES in 1987.
And boy, does it show.
Yeah. And I just mean...
So I don't want to, you know...
We should talk about the plot and the objective before we go any further.
But what I mean is, is just like, this game looks Atari 2600 level graphics, right?
Am I wrong? Yeah, I can't think of many games that look as archaic as this one.
Popeye was the last one for me.
Yes, that's what I have in my head.
I almost think Popeye looked better than this.
Well, that's what I guess I... Yeah, but remember Popeye's boat?
And then you see the boat in the arcade and you're like, wow, that's a boat.
Right, right. I was playing on a bunch of zigzags, you know?
That's how I feel with elevator action.
Only the elevator action arcade game also looked pretty similar to that.
Yeah. So here we go with the plot for elevator action, because I know everybody was looking for that
deep lore. The player assumes the role of Agent 17, code name Otto.
Now, here's...
I gotta stop right there.
I have to stop one sentence in.
Isn't it usually the other way around?
Yeah, I was just gonna say... Aren't you like Otto, code name Agent 17?
No, you are... This is like a Hitman situation where you are the barcode, but you take on a name.
Oh, okay.
Interesting. I like that. I didn't know that was Hitman's thing, actually.
Well, I don't actually know either, but I think it is Agent 17 in Hitman.
Oh, I thought... Oh, that's right!
Yeah. Oh, yeah!
Is this a prequel?
That is so strange.
Anyway... Everything's a prequel.
Everything. For us.
No matter how... And who knows?
Maybe Agent 17, right?
This Otto, code name guy from Elevator Action.
Maybe it's like his descendant is Hitman.
That could be. That makes it a prequel.
No, no, no. I meant like...
It could be just... It could be young.
I meant in a reference to the Athena episode last week, Sean.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly. In the Athena episode last week, we found out that Athena Asamiya is Athena's...
Wow, how many times have I said that?
I don't know. People are like, no less, two weeks.
Okay. Anyway, Agent 17, codename Otto, he's a secret agent for an unspecified organization...
Or government. In your country.
Like, it doesn't specify.
It doesn't even know. Organization or government who must collect all the documents and reach the basement using
the elevator and stairs.
So then, if we're gonna get into the gameplay, the player assumes the role of a spy infiltrating
a 30-story building filled with elevators.
The player is pursued by enemy agents who appear from behind closed doors.
Your mission? Collect documents and get down to the basement.
Where there is a car.
Yeah, where the plot and the gameplay come together so seamlessly.
I think there's something to be said.
Yeah, there's something to be said, like, if you can have both be the same thing.
Yeah, it was pretty much the same paragraph.
It's kind of beautiful. So what do we think about the gameplay?
I mean, I was surprised that there was so much shooting guns in this game for an NES game.
I feel like they steered clear of that.
Yeah, shooting the guns.
We've had some very violent games so far.
I guess that's true.
But, like, we had, like, Commando and stuff.
You remember the games where you took an actual gun and shot people in the face, Joe?
What? Yeah, the Zapper games.
You had an actual gun.
That wasn't people? Oh, yeah, okay.
I'm thinking of Duck Hunt.
Hogan's Alley and stuff like that.
Oh, yeah. Ducks aren't people.
Well, that's true. But fair.
There have been other gun games.
But for some reason, this one just feels more...
Maybe it's just, like, the bullets and, like, you're just killing people that are just,
like, in an office building.
All right, so, all right. So, all right. For some reason, Joe is very offended by the violence in this game.
I don't know why.
I'm not offended at all.
I just meant that I'm surprised that they, you know, I feel like people were a lot more
sensitive to that. But I think a good way to work around that is that I would have really enjoyed if this
was a Zapper game, actually.
Like, imagine if Agent 17 acts on his own, right?
Agent 17 kind of, like, does his thing walking around trying to get to the bottom without avoiding
contact. And then you are, like, the marksman across the other building shooting with the Zapper
all of the different targets that show up trying to kill him as he completes the mission.
Oh, wait, no, this has to be a multiplayer game, then.
It can only be played co-op.
No, I am saying that Agent, I'm saying Agent 17 maybe is controlled by Rob.
He is moving around little gyro discs that put the, you know, that move, like, okay,
Otto will now walk to the left.
Wow. And all those weeks ago, we were talking about how they could not think of another Rob game,
but we already made it for them.
Not only did I make a Rob game, I made a game where the Rob and the Zapper come together.
Okay? Since we're talking about gameplay, I am very impressed that you're able to control
the elevators in this game.
That's a reason for the rest?
I suppose. I mean, I think at first it, like, takes a second for you to realize that you're controlling,
because the elevators will move if you don't move them.
That's what it was. I thought the elevators, because they move on their own, I thought that I was just, like,
at their mercy, and then I just, like, I was like, oh, I got to duck, and instead
of ducking, I went down.
Yeah. I was like, huh, I'm God.
It was a neat experience, but yeah, I mean, just this, like, you must have a very low bar
for excitement if, like, I was very surprised that we could control the elevators.
I just didn't know what was possible in this game.
And if you thought I was surprised when I found out you can control the elevators, wait
until I found out you can shoot the lights out.
Yeah. Yeah, that was like, I found that out at the very end of my time playing, and I was
like, what? I could have done this the whole time?
It seemed to maybe get you more points, but didn't really do much else for you.
I don't think they react as quickly to you if you have the lights out.
And you definitely get more points.
I think it's worth, like, 500 points instead of, like, 100.
But you shoot any light in the building, and all lights in the building go out, like
the way lights work. Yeah, exactly.
You've broken the circuit.
Everybody just has that one master light switch in their living room that turns off and
on all the lights in the house.
Is this the first stealth game?
Huh. Would you say stealth, though?
I mean, you're right out in the open.
I mean, yeah, I was gonna say, like, is Super Mario Brothers a stealth game if I, like,
don't attack anybody and I just jump around everything?
Well, I think one of the biggest parts of stealth games is shooting out lights.
Yes, it's true.
I'd say it's... That was a big component of Splinter Cell.
It checks that box.
And you're also a spy, but that's, like, one of those, like, additional boxes.
Like, those are bonus boxes.
Bonus boxes.
Um, and...
How's this on the spy scale right now?
Is it, like, halfway to being a spy game?
Uh, I meant stealth.
Stealth. Okay. It's definitely a spy game because they'd say it is.
Yes. Um, but I don't know.
I think, like, I think this is, like, at least a prototype.
It's a stealth game. Here's the weird thing, okay?
If this is a spy game and it's 1983, we are...
Stealth. Stealth or spy game?
Yeah, stealth game, even.
Stealth or spy game, and it's 1983.
We are in, like, peak James Bond mode right now, where, like, Bond mania is high.
Roger Moore is Bond.
Like, you know, this is, like, all-time cheesiness levels.
Things are getting really good.
And then you get a game that's like, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, what's the most spy thing you can do?
Ride up and down the elevator and steal documents.
It's like, where is, like, the remote control car that I'm gonna use to, like, knock people down off their feet?
And where's, like, my explosive gel that I put on the door and then blow it up when they walk by?
Like, that's what I'm looking for in my spy game.
I like to imagine.
Yeah, gadgets. I mean, I do think I sound silly just now talking about the first stealth game.
No, I actually enjoy it.
Now I also have, like, this image in my head of the pitch meeting.
And it's similar to, like, how James Cameron pitched Aliens where he just wrote Aliens and then, like, made the S a dollar sign on a whiteboard.
And so I like to think that they wrote Elevators or Elevator on a whiteboard.
And then they just, like, took off a sheet and it said Action after it.
Just, like, why were they thinking Elevator?
Like, why is that the core gameplay loop?
Yeah, yeah. I mean, the only thing I can, I mean, it doesn't answer that question at all.
But the only thing I can think of is that, like, a lot of arcade games, there's, like, Burger Time.
And there's, like, all these things that I'm just like, why is this a game?
Which is also Tyto made.
Is it? Yeah, Tyto did Burger Time.
They were just picking up on all the big trends of the 80s, like Elevators.
Like Elevators. And fast food.
Yeah. I mean, like, if you think about it, though, we're kind of joking.
But, like, the 80s would see, like, a lot of high-rise construction buildings in, like, in big cities.
So this is actually a comment on the socioeconomic status of New York City in the 80s.
I don't know. Absolutely.
That's what I got from it.
All right. So inputs.
Are they responsive? Enough.
I think enough. I think what you need.
I mean, shooting's quick enough.
Shooting is quick enough. And that's really, like, the biggest thing.
Because it is you versus the other guy's bullet.
So you want to be fast.
Yeah. And I even, like, when I see the door open, I'll shoot early just to, like, anticipate how long it's going to take to travel over to them.
But the bullets are a little faster than some of the other games.
I always go back to, you know, Commando.
Commando. Yeah, the bullet was so slow that you could.
Those weren't really bullets. Those were, like, blue bubbles.
Right. But these were, like, small and they were, like, fast enough that you couldn't.
It was hard to dodge.
Oh, you had to react. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. In fact, I think most of my deaths were met by, like, just not seeing a guy at the right time and then him shooting.
And then, like, I'm trying to either duck or something and I wind up getting hit by his bullet.
Yeah. You can die also by making direct contact with people, which is weird.
Well, they grab you.
Yeah, but why can't I grab them?
Remember, this is an argument I'll always have with these games.
I think that while, yeah, the controls themselves are fine, they're perfectly passable, I do think that the ways that you do interact with the environment can get a little fickle.
Like, you have to stand, like, basically within two pixels of this white dot in order to open one of the red doors.
And that's the same for the stairs, too.
Yeah, yeah. It's just weird.
And also, why am I taking the stairs in a game about elevators?
Because that floor doesn't have stairs, Mike.
It's an escalator.
It's an escalator? Yeah, they are not.
It's a completely mechanized moving system.
I like that. The building itself is moving.
Well, confirmed.
Yeah, it's confirmed. Okay, great.
Through space. Is there enough happening in this game, though?
No. It needs something else.
It needs another little piece.
Right, because this is a game in 1987 that is living and dying by the high score mechanism.
The whole thing is how high can you score?
And it's like, that's not the experience I want to bring home into my living room.
Right. Yeah, I think this would be okay in an arcade experience.
You're just competing against whoever else trying to beat the score.
Right, that local leaderboard at your bar.
Right. Or Chuck E.
Cheese. You're just like, I'm going to be at the top.
Or Chuck E. Cheese. Yeah, or Chuck E. Cheese.
Yeah, it depends on where you are.
And then, just another question here.
Is it weird that this simple game is being released on the NES now?
1987. Would we have accepted it more in 1985 if this was a launch game?
Would we have been kinder to it?
Oh, very much so. Even us as in, the three of us?
Yes, the three of us.
I think I would have because I wasn't quite aware of what else I was getting into.
Right. And here it's like, I've seen enough good games now, I don't want to see nothing like elevator
action. I don't want to be too hard on it though, because I think at least it's something different.
I mean, I know it's a remake, it's just a port.
Mm-hmm. But it's not just a move to the right and hit stuff, or move to the right and shoot stuff,
or move to the right and jump on stuff.
Like, it's still, it's got some interesting maneuvers.
Like, it's not enough of the new stuff.
Right. But it is unique.
It is unique. Well guys, I have bad news.
Elevator action seems to have a fan base.
Seems to be pretty popular, was popular back in the day.
Kind of revered as a good game back in the day.
I don't think it's a terrible game.
I don't think that's bad news. I think that's bad news for me because I really don't like it.
But, you know, I'd be remiss if I didn't talk about all of the sequels and spinoffs that came out of Elevator Action,
like Elevator Action Returns, or just Elevator Action 2 in North America, 2 being Roman numerals.
That was released in 1994.
Okay. Wow. Yeah, that took a while to get out.
Then Elevator Action EX, which is an updated version of the game released for the Game Boy Color in 2000.
Then Elevator Action Old and New.
It's a further update for the Game Boy Advance in 2002.
And revealed that AOU 2009 Elevator Action Death Parade is a light gun shooter that uses elevator doors when changing scenarios.
That's the only way that it gets to the elevator.
Like it just, it's like, that's how it cuts?
That's how it cuts, yes.
And then a later remake of the game by Square Enix.
What? Titled Elevator Action Deluxe was released on the PlayStation Network on August 31st, 2011.
The game contains single player and multiplayer modes as well as the original arcade game.
Isn't it a massively multiplayer online game?
No, it's not. Not an MMO.
I'm sure eventually they will do Elevator Action A Realm Reborn.
But is the new version in that?
Not even a laugh. I'm sorry.
There are people laughing on the other side.
Which new version? Is the new version in that 2011 version, like not the original arcade version that they included, is the new version just like an updated looking version of the original?
Or is it like play different?
Yeah, but with some new mechanics.
But no, no, no. The idea is still the same.
You know, you're riding an elevator, you're Agent 17, you know, which is weird because Square Enix made it and Square Enix, for the most part, was responsible for Hitman back then.
I think they still are.
No, I think, didn't they hand off that license?
I don't. Pretty sure whoever's making those games now also owns the rights for that game.
Well, it's still being published by Square, right?
See, I just don't know with season two.
I know that like after season one, basically, there was like some, this really didn't make enough money for Square Enix.
So then they were like, oh, okay, we'll.
We'll take it. We'll buy it back.
Okay. I think it was for a pretty small sum too, to be honest.
A couple million. Well, going back though to, not the direct sequels and remakes of this game, but I think to the.
The legacy. The legacy of the game.
I want to say, and I don't want to put words in his mouth because he's active and this is
just speculation on my part, but the indie developer Tom Francis, one of my favorite like indie game developers,
made a game called Gunpoint.
And it's a, it bears a resemblance to this game where you have to infiltrate a building.
Um, you, you can use elevators and stairs to navigate the floors.
Um, you, you have like, it's not a zip line, but you can jump between buildings.
And I, I think that it just like has some aesthetic, uh, similarities that I think he may have a little bit of inspiration from this game.
So check out Gunpoint.
It's cheap. Uh, it's a lot of fun.
And, and just so I'm aware, cause I mean, it does sound like a little bit similar, but like in terms of the gameplay loop, how similar would you put just that one part of it with the elevators and that stuff?
How similar would you put that to elevator action?
I would say that it's, it's definitely your, your, that's not your goal is to get down to the bottom.
Like your, your goal changes depending on the mission, uh, in Gunpoint.
Um, but like in terms of some parts of navigation and, uh, the actual visual design of the game, I think that it shares some similarities.
Cool. I think that definitely for people who are into elevator action, that's worth checking out.
Uh, just be, just because they probably don't get many chances to do another gameplay loop like that.
Or, or, or just stealth games.
Like even though this is, this isn't really a stealth game.
If you're into metal gear, uh, um, and then also just for elevator action fans out there, I just want to say that like, you know, you probably, you know, if you like this game, you're probably upset that the three of us aren't crazy about it, but I will offer this.
Okay. We are Ness-stalgia.
We have no Ness-stalgia.
And, and I think that like in 2018, high scores are just as overrated as like lives, you know, like, like nobody wants like, you know, like the one up mushroom anymore in a Mario game.
It should be like, I should just have unlimited lives.
Like I don't care for that mechanic anymore.
Same way. I don't care about my score, you know?
So when the gameplay loop of these games involves, you know, like getting your score to keep going up and up and up, it's kind of like the problem Joe had with Donkey Kong, a game that because I grew up with, I was more fond of it.
But since Joe didn't really grow up with it, he was like, well, there's really only just four levels, three in the NES version.
So there's not really much there for me.
And people are gonna be like, oh, but you're supposed to keep doing them again and again and again, and they get harder and harder.
It's like, yeah, but the loop itself isn't good enough for like modern players to enjoy.
And I think that's the biggest problem with elevator action is like, once you've done the 30 floors and got into the car, you might as well shut off the system after that because it's not getting much different.
I mean, there, I, I haven't played these because I also got bored and it was just sort of smitten with the idea.
But like the, the puzzles, like the elevators do become more puzzle like later in the game.
But again, like if it didn't hold my attention for that long, I'm not going to have too much fun with the puzzle element either.
So that's, that's my two cents, Hunter.
Any other stray thoughts?
I don't think so.
I'll give you a weird one while Joe decides if he has any.
There is a great article that I'm going to link on the show notes.
The show notes are always available at NostalgiaCast.com.
And there's a great article for on elevator design, specifically elevator design in this game from Elevator World Incorporated.
They are like a real elevator building company.
You know, like they build elevators and they like are a big multinational unit.
And they did an article on like, just like, like the, the enthusiasm.
How the elevators work? Yeah, how the elevators work.
In this game specifically. And like, just a sign of the times of like, yes, elevators were a big thing.
And this shows like, you know, like that there was a whole game around it.
And like, they just reminisce about like this game that essentially was like their moment in the spotlight.
They said elevators were a big thing.
Like really? I'll just give you a little.
I mean, they are a big thing. I'll give you a little sample here if the web page is willing to load.
Here we go. The phrase golden age evokes a variety of images.
You know, like that's, that's something right there off the bat.
And then they kind of give us a little bit of history.
Webster's Dictionary describes elevator.
And then they have like this amazing like elevator chart where like they show where the elevators can be.
And stuff like that.
And it goes, this planning coupled with the fact that no elevators serve the 18th floor reflects the game designers goal to make it as difficult as possible to navigate through the building, which was, of course, the idea.
I just love that this article exists, no less from Elevator World Incorporated, whose tagline is publisher for the international building transportation industry.
So that's my straight thought.
A very straight. That is very straight.
You know, I think that's, I think that's straight enough for both of us.
Okay, very good. Let's move right on into the essential games list.
Okay. So you have elevator action.
And then you have the ability to ride an elevator at work.
Okay. I'm not going to say that I'm going to choose between the two, which one's better, right?
But there's definitely a difference in the gameplay loop of each of those to offer an experience for both.
With that in mind, Sean, can you please take me through your vote for elevator action on the essential games list?
So here's the thing about riding the elevator and like at your workplace.
When you get off the elevator, you have to go to work.
But whereas when you get off the elevator in this game, you get into a bitchin hot rod and make off with some secret documents.
So that's why it's essential.
It's not essential.
It's not a very good game.
I just think it's, it's cute.
It's a cute game.
That's my non-essential vote.
Joseph. It keeps my attention for a little bit.
It was fun for like a few minutes.
It was fun. It was interesting.
But yeah, I'm not going to, I'm not going to try and get much further in it.
You know, it's just, we kind of said it all.
It just, it's repetitive and it kind of gets old.
Yeah. I'm a hard no.
It's inessential.
I'm sorry to the fans, but hopefully you're still my fan.
That was lame. All right.
That is all the time we have for this episode of Nostalgia.
Sean, I heard that there might be a website people can reach us at.
We took that down.
Oh. Yeah, we didn't tell you.
Sean and I took it down.
We replaced it with mics without mic.
Oh, okay. Yeah, that thing that shows up once every blue moon.
Anyway, the website I was referring to, which is definitely still up and is being worked very hard on,
and is the place where you find show notes and articles and links to all of these cool games.
That would be NostalgiaCast.com.
N-E-S-T-A-L-G-I-A-Cast.com.
There was no way you wrote that down as I was doing each letter, because I'd have to be like N as in Nintendo, E as in entertainment.
You get where I'm going.
Anyway, I hope you had a good time with this elevator action episode.
I didn't really have a good time playing it, but I had a good time recording this episode, and I always have a good time when you tell me how you feel about the episodes,
whether that be on Twitter, we are at contact NostalgiaCast, or if you tell me in email, which is contact at NostalgiaCast.com,
or if you somehow get a hold of my personal phone number and decide to call me, I don't have that information readily available for anybody,
but kudos to you, I guess, if you find that.
Please don't contact me at that number.
If you want, like, phone number, email me.
You can call me if you find my email, yeah.
Very cool. Considering you guys have only given your last names once, I'll take that bet.
I'm Michael Esposito, and you can find me on at Esposito Film on Twitter, and I'll talk to you soon.
All right, and welcome to the post show.
So, guys, today we're going to talk about elevators.
All right. What are your feelings?
The elevators in my office really suck.
You have a really bad elevator at your office.
I was going to tell you about that, actually, every single time I ride it, because I'd rather take the stairs.
When was the last time you rode the elevator there?
At your office?
Yeah. Hmm.
Now it would have to be, like, earlier this year or so.
Oh, okay, earlier this year?
Yeah. So, yeah, those are the new elevators.
Yeah. And the problem is, is, like, there's only two.
Mm-hmm. They're very slow.
There's a lot of floors.
Yeah. And no one is pointing a gun at me when I get out of them.
Elevators here, though, really cool.
We have, like, 12, 24.
We have 24 elevators, and...
Each one has a different theme.
You know, this is just something that, like, I wish you wouldn't do.
Each one has a different experience. You'd have all these, like, you know what?
My elevators are better.
I'm on the 39 floor.
Oh. You know what a rush you get.
Yeah. Wow. When it goes right.
My elevators are better than yours. Have you guys ever been stuck in an elevator?
Yes. Yes, I have.
I actually am not.
I didn't think... I was momentarily stuck, though.
I was stuck for about eight minutes in my elevator at work,
and then I literally had to push it open.
Because there was still a little bit of it open on my side,
and I threw my back out doing it.
Wow. But then I broke the elevator.
You got out, though.
I got out. Were you flush with the ground?
What? Was the elevator on a level, or was it in between floors?
Oh, no, it was at the second floor.
It just wouldn't open the door or go down to anything.
Oh, that makes me feel a little better.
So you probably weren't going to get cut in half trying to get down?
No, it was just a pain in the ass, because I was going on a little adventure.
Here's a hot tip.
Press the floor you want to go on, like up to,
and then press the door close button at the same exact time,
so you kind of got to do like a claw with your finger, you know,
and you take your index finger and your thumb.
Or use two hands. That's perfectly fine, too.
That's a pro tip for you.
I like to think it only works with one hand.
And you push both of them at the same time, and you hold on it the entire ride,
and it will go express.
I think that's a myth. Are you serious?
It's always worked for me.
It has always worked for me every single time.
Wow, I've never. That can't be.
I think it's just like an emergency thing.
I feel like I've heard that. I feel like it's one of those urban legends that I've never actually tested.
You should test it. It's worked for me.
And what's the worst thing that happens?
If the door stops and it opens, that's it.
No one notices you're jamming the door closed sign.
You would have enough time to let go.
That's fair. That's the elevator tip of the day.
And if you want to subscribe to Elevator Facts, be sure to contact me at contact.nostalgiacast.com.
And just make the subject Elevator Facts.
We'll make sure we do not send you any NES facts.
We will just send you Elevator Facts.
There is no one subscribed.
Yep. But if you do also want NES facts for some reason, and you just give me the subject NES facts,
I will kindly direct you to our Twitter page, which every day posts NES facts, actually.
It's really cool. All right.
I can only imagine.
But the post show is supposed to be, like, super casual, isn't it?
We should do a show. We should do a show after that.
Yeah. We should plug more.
Didn't we just do that?
Welcome to the post post show.
We're going to talk about plugs.
This now takes place inside of an elevator's dream.
Okay. Guys, what do you think elevators dream about?
I don't think they dream.
I think that they dream about actually having a hatch in the top of them, like they do in all the movies.
But I don't think I've ever been in an elevator where I could, like, climb out a hatch of them.
Well, how often do you look at the ceiling?
Every single time.
Every time. Because I'm like, where's the hatch?
Oh. Actually, it's funny that you bring this up in no less an episode about spies, because
in the Roger Moore, James Bond classic, A View to a Kill, he not only gets stuck in an elevator
like Sean, but the building is on fire.
And so he has to use the escape before, you know, and he has a, of course, he has his Bond
girl with him, and, you know, they open up the hatch and they have to get out of there
before the fire consumes them.
So a little bit of elevator action.
Yeah. It is elevator action.
It's everywhere. When you guys hear the word elevator action, what does that make you think of?
I think it's two words.
Elevator action. Does that sound like an innuendo?
Elevator action. Like for having sex in an elevator?
It's like elevaction.
Like I love action.
I love action. Oh, elevaction.
Elevator action. Are either one of you going to seek out the sequels for this game?
The squeakwills, you mean?
The squeakwills, yes.
The Rob Hacks with the chipmunks.
No, I mean, I'd rather play Gunpoint.
Buy Gunpoint.
Sorry. He doesn't even make any commission off of that.
It's crazy. It's so cool.
He's such a cool guy. I just like Gunpoint.
Subscribe to Tito, please.
Okay, that's all.
Goodbye. Goodbye.!